Hallo Stefan, wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon.
Richtig.
Haben heute sehr viel zu tun, denn wir müssen über das Buch sprechen, über das alle sprechen, aber das nicht alle gelesen haben vielleicht, nämlich die vierte Gewalt von Harald Wälzer und Richard David Precht. Das steht heute an und dann haben wir noch weitere Texte natürlich parat. Aber du hast mir vorab jetzt schon gesagt, du hast dich noch mal mit dem Thema Jawline in ganz neuer Weise beschäftigt.
Ja, es war so, ich war Examenspatient, eine angehende Zahnmedizinerin, musste also Prüfungsleistung ablegen und hat rumgefragt, wer braucht denn hier eine Beißschiene? Und ich habe mich gemeldet, habe gesagt, ich, mein Kiefer knackt. Und daraufhin habe ich mich sofort qualifiziert, denn die gehen dann so eine Liste durch, ah, so ein Kiefergelenk, das nicht rund läuft. Okay, war ich also da ungefähr sechs Tage lang, jeweils über drei Stunden und dann wurden alles möglich gemacht. Jedes Mal Befund, also jede einzelne Zahn hier, kreuz und quer. Ich fühle mich auch seitdem bestens durchdiagnostiziert, weil dann auch bei kleinsten Fragen einfach jeder Experte bis hin zu Koryphäen der Beißleistenherstellung und so weiter, dann kurz vorbeitanzen. Und die haben ja nun die größte Bandbreite an Patienten vor sich. Also ein Saal mit 60 Behandlungstischen, Stühlen, so musst du es vorstellen, wie in so einem Film. Und jedenfalls liege ich da so rum und dann stellt sich heraus, mein Kiefer ist nicht nur so ein bisschen locker, sondern ich knirsche auch anscheinend nachts oder beiße so drauf und wie auch immer. Und daraufhin fängt die Zahnärztin, also die ganze Riegel, da so an, mich abzutasten. Und meine dann so, oh sie sind da jede Nacht im Fitnessstudio. Stellt sich raus, alles das, was wir besprochen haben, hinsichtlich, man kann diesen Kiefermuskel hier trainieren, ist bei mir aufs Maximale getrimmt. Also die haben, die meinten, wir haben noch nie so einen krassen Kiefermuskel gesehen und so. Und wenn ich so zusammenbeise, sehe ich auch, ja, der ist dann halt auf der linken Seite, hat wirklich eine Kante, so ne? Also so eine richtige John-Line-Kante. Aber mir fiel dann auf, man muss zubeißen. Also wenn die ihre Fotos machen so, die müssen dann wirklich kurz bewusst, ach ja, ich muss jetzt beißen, weil dann kommt der Muskel da raus. Und es ist wirklich verrückt, weil der Typ meint dann zu mir und ich so, es ist ja verrückt, ich hab vor einer Woche in meinem Podcast darüber gesprochen und das war nicht mein Thema und dann wird John-Line gesprochen und so. Und er meinte, ja, das ist im Grunde, es gibt das, dass man diese besonders festen Kaugummis und so weiter. Und das sind dann auch die kommenden Patienten.
Weil die machen sich einfach die Zähne kaputt, die Oberblände.
Genau, also diese Verlast ist nicht gut. Und wenn der Muskel einmal da ist, hast du auch in diesen angespannten Situationen, gerade in der Nacht und so weiter, ist es halt besonders hoher Druck. Weil du hast ja mehr Muskeln und so. Und es gibt dann verschiedene... Also bei mir ist jetzt so, der Kiefer muss zwei Millimeter weiter auseinander. Und der Unterkiefer muss auch 1, 5 Kilometer nach vorne. Ich habe also jetzt eine Beißleiste, die bis zum Weißheiz... Ich habe noch alle Weißheizszene bis zum Zahn 8 jeweils geht. Und mir diese neue Kieferposition antrainiert, indem nämlich auch unten an der Beißleiste ein Rejev ist. Also ganz ausgefeiltes Zeug. Und damit entlastet ich jetzt nachts mein Diskus rechter Hand. Es wird sich auch neues Gewebe bilden und so. Also es sind große Umbaumaßnahmen durch kleine Interventionen. Ist alles nicht so schlimm. Die meinten, das ist nur Vorsorge, damit ihnen nicht in 30 Jahren die Bänder und so weiter. Aber die Gegenmaßnahme gegen dieses Sie haben da zu starke Muskeln ist zum Beispiel, dass ich jetzt jeden Abend für ein, zwei Übungen mit dem Zeigefinger ganz hinten in meinen Rachen reinreiche. Und den Kiefermuskel von innen noch mitdehne, während ich meinen Mund langsam öffne, damit der Muskel wieder ein bisschen mehr Spielraum bekommt und auch gedehnt wird und so.
Und verschwindet jetzt deine Jawline? Nein.
Also ich weiß es nicht. So ausgeprägt ist er. Also sichtlich ist er. Sie meinten beim Fühlen so, das haben wir noch nie erlebt, dass man so viel Muskel dahaben kann. Und jetzt muss ich das wieder zurück trainieren sozusagen. Also den Muskel dehnen, eine neue Ruheposition finden. Und stell dir mal vor, jemand hätte vor fünf Jahren in so einem YouTube-Video mir gesagt, mach das mal und dann gehe ich so klar, kann ich Ex-Amtspatient werden und dann sagen die, ach du große Neune. Also wenn sie mit 60 noch einen funktionierenden Kiefer haben wollen, dann machen sie immer das, das, das und das. Und trainieren sie mal wieder ab.
Dann füllen sie mal auf, diese Kaugummis zu kauen.
Und da habe ich auch gedacht wieder, ey, das ist wirklich... Leute, hört auf mit diesem Unfug. Lasst eure Jawline in Ruhe. Am Ende, es sind ein, zwei Millimeter, die man da drauf trainieren kann, optisch. Es ist völlig Banane eigentlich. Aber gut, das ist diese kleine Pointe. Ansonsten kann ich sehr empfehlen, werdet Examenspatienten. Gerade hier in Frankfurt oder so, wo es große Unikliniken gibt. Es wird für alles ausgebildet und alle brauchen irgendwelche Patienten, die einfach nur viel Zeit haben, um da zu sein. Selten fühlt man sich so durch diagnostiziert wie da. Weil da kommt einfach jeder nochmal mit seiner Spezialbrille, guckt nochmal genau diese Fraktur am Weißheitszahn. Ja, ist nicht so schlimm, aber wir haben einmal drauf geguckt, wir wissen jetzt Bescheid. Und so hab ich mir auch gedacht, jeder normale Mensch geht einfach zum Zahnarzt und der sagt so, ja ja, ich hab mal geguckt, kommst du im halben Jahr wieder. Und dort passiert das nicht. Also dort gehst du unter neun Stunden oder so nicht raus. Und dann weißt du aber, ja, wenn die jetzt sagen, ist alles in Ordnung, dann braucht man wirklich erst ein halbes Jahr. In der Hinsicht kann man sich da nochmal ein paar Experten, eine plurale Meinungsbildung findet da statt. Über den nämlich nicht sehr eindeutigen menschlichen Körper und seine Zustände. Also kann ich sehr empfehlen, wenn man die Zeit hat. Aber das durchschnittliche Patientengespräch in Deutschland dauert ja sieben Minuten und es wird ja natürlich auch nicht ausgebaut. Ich hab ja darüber geschrieben. Und da findet man die Zeit. Also wenn man richtig einen Arzt haben will, der einmal alles erklärt, da geht einfach als Examenspatient oder Proband, sagen wir lieber, man ist ja nicht wirklich Patient, geht man als Examensproband in alle möglichen Fachrichtungen, die sich so anbieten.
Expertenpluralität, das ist ja schon fast das Stichwort zu unserem Hauptthema heute im Salon. Aber ich habe einen Podcast gehört, der sehr bekannt ist, nämlich Hotel Matze, denn dort war Kuppersbusch zu Gast. Friedrich Kuppersbusch. Du kennst ihn glaube ich sogar persönlich oder hast ihn mal kennengelernt.
Wir hatten ihn mal auf der Bühne, war sehr interessant.
Er ist Journalist und er ist auch Produzent von mehreren Sendungen gewesen, wie zum Beispiel Bauerfeind oder Maischberger. Und jetzt produziert er gerade Sheik Römer und weitere Formate. Und er äußert sich in diesem Podcast Hotel Matze auch zu diesen Medienthemen. Und er hat offenbar das Buch von Precht und Welser noch nicht gelesen, aber er sagt, die haben da ja auch jetzt sich mit beschäftigt. Und die sind dann auch, glaube ich, irgendwann zu Gast. Jedenfalls hören wir jetzt mal von ihm so seine Einschätzung dazu. Wir hören mal in den ersten Clip rein.
Das Beispiel mag ein bisschen skurril klingen, aber als bei der sogenannten Wolf-Affäre auf einmal alle süddeutsche FAZ-Spiegel bei der Bild abschrieben, wo ich als älterer Diskursteilnehmer noch weiß, dass wenn die Bild X sagte, sagten alle anderen erstmal Y. Alleine schon Erdpusteligkeit und Schweinejournalismus und so. Also es gibt schon so eine Elite, die Themen macht und schmiedet und durchzieht.
Womit wir hier Konzert markieren. Im Salon lesen wir das Buch ganz ausführlich. Es gibt ganz viel dazu zu sagen. Ich habe mir noch nie sieben Seiten Notizen zu irgendeiner Lektüre gemacht. Jetzt reden wir nur über den Diskurs drumherum, obwohl du vorher sagtest, du wirst dich für das Drumherum nicht interessieren. Ich werde gleich noch ein paar Anmerkungen zur Land-Sendung machen, wo sie zu Gast waren und jetzt zurück zur Körpersbusch.
Genau. Hören wir doch gleich. Also erst mal haben wir hier einen Menschen aus den Medien, der sagt, ja klar gibt es da im Prinzip Leitwölfe, die schon auch dann gemeinsam hin und wieder so Aktionen durchziehen, wie das jetzt im Falle Wolf war.
Also meine berufliche Erfahrung, meine ich, muss mir sagen, es gibt einen Krieg der Kriegerinnen und Krieger, der besteht daraus, sich gegenseitig zu verstümmeln und zu ermorden, und es gibt einen Krieg der Narrative. Und das, was wir hier erleben, der Russe hat Narrative, wir haben die Wahrheit, ist nach aller menschheitsgeschichtlichen Erfahrung nicht wahr, sondern natürlich hat der Russe Narrative, die sind haarsträumt und verlogen und propagandistisch, und wir haben auch welche. Und der journalistische Blick sollte das wissen, und sollte versuchen, alles der Narrative zu entkleiden.
Es ist so einfach, es genau so zu sagen, und man hat damit so viel Recht. Und es ist so erstaunlich, auf was für taube Ohren man in diesen Redaktionen heute stößt, die ja dann auch wirklich ihre Botschafter nach außen schicken, in die Land-Sendungen und wo auch immer hin, um da einfach ihre Narrative durchzudrücken. Also wer die Sendung mit Lands gesehen hat und nicht glaubt, dass Melanie Ahnmann einen Krieg dort führt, dass sie sich gerade im Krieg der Information sieht, beispielsweise gegen Precht und Wälzer, der muss echt noch mal seinen Fokus überprüfen. Und Kippersbush bietet hier, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Fokus an auf das alles.
Ja, denn wir sprechen ja jetzt hier über Light-Journalisten. Es geht hier jetzt nicht darum, und das können wir ja schon mal vorwegnehmen, Precht und Wälzer geht es jetzt nicht darum, einen Rundumschlag zu machen, dass alle Journalisten nicht mehr vernünftig arbeiten oder so. Und dass der redaktionelle Alltag von den, ich sage mal in Anführungszeichen, normalen Journalisten, völlig anders ist, als der von Robin Alexander und Melanie Ahmann, dürfte eigentlich allen Leuten klar sein. Und es dürfte auch klar sein, dass wir auf verschiedenen Ebenen des Journalismus andere Standards haben und auch ganz anders gearbeitet wird. Also zum Beispiel im Lokaljournalismus funktioniert Journalismus vollkommen anders. Und er ist auch deshalb vielleicht gerade so interessant und stark. Natürlich gibt es da auch mitunter mal eine Kampagne oder so was. Und da gibt es auch mal Ansagen. Und man bekommt ja auch immer direkt mit, wer den Artikel gelesen hat, wenn man im Lokalen unterwegs ist. Aber wir haben natürlich nicht diese, ich habe hier jetzt so eine Meinung, die ich vorher auch stark abdecke mit dem, was die anderen sagen. Und dann machen wir so ein ganz lautes Sprachrohr daraus. Aber jetzt gehe ich schon fast zu weit wieder. Wir werden dann noch weiter. Aber die Überlegung jetzt erst mal von Körpersbusch ist, natürlich wird immer in Kriegen mit Narrativen gearbeitet. Und diese gilt es zu hinterfragen. Und zwar auf beiden Seiten. Und wir machen das tatsächlich kaum. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das gar nicht stattfindet, aber wir machen es kaum. Und wir machen es vor allem dort nicht, wo die großen Quoten erreicht werden in den Talkshows. Also man kann natürlich jetzt quantitative Erhebungen machen und wird am Ende rausfinden, es gab aber so und so viel Prozent von Artikeln, die das gemacht haben. Nur wenn das in Le Monde Diplomatique auf Seite 7 steht, dann ist das ein Unterschied, als wenn es bei Maisberger am Abend stattfindet.
Also wir wissen, also sagen wir so, manchmal gibt es so Zäsuren und dann kann man sich nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern, wie es vorher eigentlich war. Dieser Krieg ist ja mittlerweile in jedes Gemüt so richtig rein, hat sich richtig reingefressen. Und eigentlich wissen wir doch noch so ein bisschen, ich versuche es jetzt mal, vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere, bis Russland die Ukraine überfallen hat, also bis Putin diesen Eingriffsbefehl tatsächlich gab, der sich eine Weile anbahnte. Und dann auch lange noch, ist ja nur Medientheater und so weiter, also bis es Realität wurde. War die Ukraine für ein Land, das auf dem Coolness-Level von Rumänien, Kroatien, Bosnien, Herzegowina oder so was war. Es hat uns null interessiert, dass man dort nur ein Zehntel auf die individuelle Wirtschaftsleistung, Klammer auf Einkommen, Klammer zu, wie Deutschland kam, war uns total egal. Wir wussten nicht, wie viel Weizen wir von dort bekommen, wie relevant das alles ist, wie die Zusammenhänge sind. All das, und da überspannen wir jetzt Jahrzehnte, seit der Deutschen Einheit irgendwie, diese Blick auf den Osten und erst recht auf den ganz äußeren Osten, hat sich so schnell gewandelt, dass wir plötzlich der Ukraine so eine Hollywood Coolness andichten. Wir kennen Silensky und jetzt haben wir seine Frau da gesehen im Europaparlament und so weiter. Und da ist man noch gar nicht auf einer inhaltlichen oder auf einer Sachebene, sondern nur auf dieser Gefühlsebene. Wie reden wir heute über die Ukraine? Das sind jetzt plötzlich so unsere Freunde und da lassen wir vieles gar nicht durchgehen. Jede Kommunikation wird gleich geprüft, ob sie denn auf der Beziehungsebene auch angemessen dem ukrainischen Freund gerecht wird und so weiter. Obwohl das alles medial hergestellt wurde im letzten halben Jahr durch verschiedene Prinzipien und so weiter. Und diese Idee von ja im Krieg stirbt als erstes die Wahrheit oder eben das, was man vorher als Wahrheit, ich würde sagen im Krieg wird zuerst mal die Wahrheit ausgetauscht, weil die Wahrheit ist vorher so wenig wahr wie nachher. Man hat dann einfach so eine neue Sicht auf die Sache. Und wir finden die Ukraine jetzt einfach gerade total cool. Und es ist aber alles Produkt und das muss man echt sagen. Auch, also ich wage jetzt mal ein Argument, von dem ich glaube, das gehört zu denen, die sich Precht nicht zutraut. Wenn Precht nämlich sagt, man darf gar nicht mehr richtig sagen, was man so vermutet, denn dann kriegt man gleich die, er macht es ja gar nicht so auf sich bezogen. Er ist ja eher Anwaltschaft derjenigen, die am Anfang des Buches auch zitiert werden, nämlich die sozusagen vom medialen Betrieb ausgeschlossene Bevölkerung, die nur Publikum ist. Aber meiner Vermutung nach würde Precht gerne mal so ein Argument machen, wie ich habe damals nicht zu unrecht die Ukraine für nicht verteidigungsfähig gehalten und deswegen gesagt, lieber kapitulieren als und wir wissen noch gar nicht, wie viel Tode und wie viel Leid es da jetzt gibt. Aber und dann müsste Precht eigentlich wahrscheinlich sagen, ich habe unterschätzt, wie viele tausend Menschen im Pentagon arbeiten und die Chance nutzen, jetzt Russland mal richtig eins auszuwischen. Und zwar nicht nur auf so einer semantischen hier und da und jetzt machen wir mal noch eine Konferenz gegen die, sondern so richtig wir schicken jetzt Waffen und die werden dann auch gegen Russland abgeschossen. So, denn Russland hat den großen Fehler gemacht da anzugreifen, also haben sich sehr viele westliche Militärs und Strategen, die das seit Jahrzehnten sich auch persönlich wünschen, mal die Gelegenheit genutzt und haben gesagt, okay, dann schicken wir nicht nur 8000 Tonnen Waffen wie damals, als Hillary Clinton fast Präsidentin geworden wäre und man ungefähr wusste, wie die Geschichte so weitergegangen wäre, sondern dann kam Donald Trump und dann ist das mal alles ausgekühlt. Und wir hatten dieses alberne Telefonat, von dem Trump dann noch im Nachhinein meinte, ich hab Silensky nicht erpresst mit, ich unterstütze dich nicht weiter mit 400 Millionen Militärhilfe, es sei denn du sagst so und so bei CNN und so weiter, das führte ja alles zu seinem ersten Impeachment-Verfahren, das ja auch wirklich erfolgreich gegen ihn war, auch wenn er denn nicht vom Senat des Amtes enthoben wurde. Also es ist ja eine total aufgeladene Geschichte. Und man hat natürlich ohne Ende Waffen geliefert, und zwar ganz transparent. Und man fordert immer mehr. Das ist eigentlich die größte Leistung, finde ich, dass man immer mehr Waffen fordert, ohne sich persönlich zu investieren, denn wir wollen ja keine Kriegspartei werden, wir dürfen kein Personal schicken, nur Waffen. Wir sitzen also irgendwie doch ganz schön in der Falle.
Machen hier den Zuschauer-Rängen, wie Habermas sagt, sitzen wir bei der ganzen Sache. Und ich glaube, es ist auch das wichtig zu unterstreichen, was du jetzt gerade da angedacht hast. Es geht ja nicht darum, dass wir hier über irgendwelche Verschwörungen oder so reden, sondern wir haben ja es mit einer ganz transparenten Politik zu tun, wo Joe Biden sagt, dass wir dort entsprechend einschreiten müssen und es in den NATO-Staaten eine große Einigkeit darüber gibt. Es gibt im Grunde eine ganz große Eintracht in der NATO. Ja, das muss ja auch hier besonders betont werden, weil so getan würde, als würde Deutschland einen abstrusen Sonderweg gehen. Nein, es ist auch immer Teil des Bündnisses. Und natürlich gibt es dann kleine Hakelichkeiten. Aber im Grundsatz ist man sich vollkommen einig. Und ich glaube, dass Precht tatsächlich unterschätzt hat, dass es da diese große Eintracht gibt. Und das Zweite, was er wahrscheinlich unterschätzt hat, ist, dass es doch noch genügend Patriotismus oder Heroismus gibt bei den Ukrainern, dass sie also nicht in großen Teilen sagen, ohne uns dieser Krieg, wir machen da nicht mit oder so, sondern dass sehr viele oder vielleicht eine Mehrzahl sogar sagt, ich opfere mich zur Not für mein Land. Das sei denen auch unbenommen, das zu tun. Also das geht ja immer dann so, wie willst du denen verbieten, dass die für ihr Land kämpfen? Nein, jeder darf sich natürlich selbst verteidigen und so. Nur die Frage stellt sich ja erst dann, was ist oder die Frage ist erst entscheidend, wie verhalten wir uns dazu? Also inwieweit muss man genau diesen Kampf um die Selbstverteidigung unterstützen? Wie weit kann dabei die Unterstützung gehen, ohne dass wir riskieren, zum Beispiel eine nukleare Eskalation? Und das ist ja die Sache. Also wir haben es ja jetzt nicht mit der Frage zu tun. Und das ist natürlich auch wieder, ich muss es anders formulieren. Es ist ja so, dass durch diese offenen Briefe tatsächlich auch da Formulierungen gebracht wurden, wo das so aussah am Ende, dass die Ukrainer sich mal ergeben sollen. Und ich glaube, dadurch hat man nicht, also man hat nicht mehr getrennt zwischen den Ukrainern, die dort für ihre Freiheit kämpfen und das, was ihnen wichtig ist, und den westlichen Verbündeten, die auch nochmal eigene Interessen daran haben. Und ich glaube, dass man das nicht mehr so trennscharf gehalten hat, das hatte dann so eine Art von, naja, jetzt lässt man die Ukrainer, die wollen, dass man die Ukrainer im Stich lässt. Ich glaube, das ist diese Konstellation, die dann auch durch unsaubere Formulierungen entstanden ist.
Ja, es gibt so ganz viele Narrative westlicherseits, und das finde ich sehr gut, dass Külpersbusch meint, ja, der Russer hat Motive, wir haben ja nur die Wahrheit. Also, ist es der ukrainische Heroismus, der zu diesem Erfolg führte, oder vielleicht doch die Unterstützung des Westens? Denn wir in Deutschland fordern immer schwere Waffen. Aber ich meine, so eine Haubitze, wer die mal gesehen hat, würde man da sagen, das ist eine leichte Waffe. Das ist ja irgendwie total absurd. Dann als zweites Narrativ dieses, ja, unsere Wirtschaftssanktionen funktionieren nicht so richtig, weil Russland Ausweichbewegungen zu anderen Ländern, anderen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen hat und so weiter. Nee, wer sich Russland gerade mal anschaut, diese Wirtschaftssanktionen funktionieren ganz wunderbar. Vielleicht sogar noch mehr, als man sich das vorher selbst erträumt hat, hier auf westlicher Seite angefangen bei dieser Blockierung dieser Zentralbankgelder. Und so kann man das wirklich mal in der Reihe nach durchgehen, mit was wir es hier eigentlich zu tun haben. Und nichts davon ist per se alternativlos. Diese Vorstellung, und da muss man halt sagen, ja, so läuft ja das Mediengeschäft, dass man derzeit nicht große Leitartikel zu anderen Themen schreiben kann, als zu denen, die, und da ist die große Einigkeit da. Wir haben ja Ursula von der Leyen gehört, bei ihrer State of the Union-Adresse, wie sie da noch mal den Heroismus hervorhebt und den Häuserkampf lobt und so weiter. Und genauso werden auch die Leitartikel geschrieben.
Und wir können schon mal diagnostizieren, wir sitzen Ende dieses Jahrzehnts gemeinsam hier und werden garantiert über etwas sprechen, was jetzt gerade entschieden wurde. Das kann die Kooperation mit Aserbaidschan sein, das können die Waffenlieferungen nach Saudi-Arabien sein. Das wird dann irgendwelche Effekte haben, über die wir beide dann sprechen werden. Und wahrscheinlich wird dann ein mediales Narrativ sein. Wir hätten uns nicht in die Abhängigkeit von Saudi-Arabien derart bringen müssen. Wir hätten niemals da Waffen. Also man wird wieder, wie man jetzt sagt, wir hätten da mit Russland das nie so machen dürfen. Wir hätten nie diese Abhängigkeit machen. Ist ja alles richtig, das sozusagen. Nur, das ist immer retrospektiv sehr gut erkannt. Aber die Stimmen, die das früh gesagt haben, wurden nicht gehört. Und jetzt ist es ja auch wieder so, dass die Leute, die sagen, guck doch, wir können da nicht Waffen nach Saudi-Arabien nehmen. Wir können nicht mit dem Aliyev solche komischen Deals machen. Da sagt man, ja, es drängt die Zeit und so weiter. Und jetzt seid mal still. Und wir greifen da schon auch mal irgendwann auf. Hat auch über Menschenrechte gesprochen, heißt es ja dann immer, wenn ein Politiker dort vor Ort war. Und dann ist das aber jetzt erst mal passé, bis dann irgendein Konflikt eskaliert, was immer das dann sein wird. Und dann gibt es aber wieder eine einträchtige, einhellige Meinung dazu, dass man da viel zu lax umgegangen sei. Und das hätte man ja nie machen sollen. Und dieses Mal, und das ist dann immer wieder das Versprechen, wird alles anders.
Genau.
Und das löst sich aber dann nicht ein.
Richtig. Genau dieser Punkt, dieses dritte große Narrativ, was ich jetzt noch kurz aufziehen wollte. Und man hört schon, dass wir über den Krieg reden, aber wirklich nur als Kulisse für diese eigentliche Argumentation. Und ja, wir werden am Jahrzehntende auch noch über die Ukraine reden. Denn diese Vorstellung, man muss den Krieg nur richtig führen und dann hört er auch irgendwann auf. Die ist natürlich totaler Quatsch. Dieser Krieg wird in dieser Form natürlich nicht aufhören, vor allem nicht, wenn wir ihn so wirtschaftlich führen. Wir haben gar keinen Maßstab dafür, wann ist hier irgendwas erfolgreich und wann wird es aufhören? Und da haben wir ja nur von Ursula von der Leyen gehört, das wird niemals aufhören. Also da gibt es gar kein Kriterium wie nach Putin oder so wird es besser oder wenn da irgendwelche Landgewinne dann doch mal irgendwie festgeschrieben wurden. Jetzt haben wir von Schein-Referenten da gesehen. Demnächst, wenn die Ukraine dann irgendwie Ansprüche hat, wird dann in Deutschland natürlich das Wort Schein wieder weggenommen und dann sind es wieder echte giltige Verträge, die dann auch sofort völkerrechtlich anerkannt werden. Nämlich die Integrität der Grenze wie vorher, das kennen wir ja von Olaf Scholz, ist immer das Wichtigste und zwar auch völlig zu Recht. Das Grenzen nicht verschoben werden. Alles andere, woanders stattfindet. Aber diese Auseinandersetzung hat ja so kein Ende. Und du hast ja im Presseclub das richtige Wort dafür gefunden. Autokratenportfolio. Das Problem, das wir mit Wladimir Putin haben als unser Handelspartner, und wir sehen ja jetzt gerade, jetzt wo wir unsere Karten auf dem Tisch legen, Uniper ist natürlich eine staatliche Veranstaltung. Alles war vorher nur Schauspiel mit diesem. Wir lassen das mal den Markt machen und haben da so ein CEO, der privatwirtschaftlich organisiert ist. Nein, im Zweifel, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, ist das eine staatliche Einrichtung, die nicht pleite geht und damit war es von Anfang an eine staatliche Sache, die wir gemacht haben. Also wir als deutscher Staat haben mit dem russischen Staat Geschäfte gemacht hinsichtlich dieser Energielieferung. So, und das Problem, was wir mit Vladimir Putin als Handelspartner haben, ist nicht, dass er die Menschenrechte nicht einhält, sondern dass er uns erpressen kann. Und deswegen verbreitern wir jetzt einfach nur das Autokratenportfolio, um nicht von einem abhängig zu sein, sondern dann Ausweichbewegungen zu machen. Und dann haben wir ja schon von Ursula von der Leyen gehört. Es gibt dennächst so einen Katalog. Wir bewerten die Handelspartner nach verschiedenen Gesichtspunkten, wie Menschenrechte. Aber nur weil wir sie dann unten auf die Liste handeln, wir nicht so gerne mit stehen haben, heißt es ja nicht, dass wir nicht mit ihnen handeln, sondern wir haben uns nur kurz verständigt darüber, dass uns jetzt bewusst ist, dass wir eigentlich nicht so gerne mit ihnen handeln, aber dann trotzdem mit ihnen handeln. Wir haben also ein Autokratenportfolio verbreitert. Und das holt uns natürlich wieder ein. Denn wenn wirklich stimmt, dass wir hier einen Systemstreit haben und gegen Russland als Regierung, die die Menschenrechte nicht achtet, kämpfen, dann können wir nicht Ausweichbewegungen zu anderen machen, bei denen genau dasselbe Problem ist. Weil dann wäre es auch egal. Also dann ist das ganze investierte, was wir jetzt und wir bremsen ja unsere Volkswirtschaftlich auch. Also wir haben ja extreme Opportunitätskosten durch dieses Ausbremsen, durch die Energiepolkots. Dann ist das einfach egal. Weil dann kämpfen wir gar nicht gegen Putin, sondern gegen ein Problem, das wir gerade gar nicht lösen. Denn in diesem Katalog der Abhängigkeiten von Menschenrechtsmissachtenden Autokratien sind wir auf dem gleichen Level wie vorher. Es sind halt nur sachlich andere. Also man kann sehr viele Zeitungsartikel darüber schreiben, die dann davon handeln, es ist nicht mehr Putin, von dem wir abhängig sind. Aber dann werden die anderen Zeitungsartikel nicht geschrieben. Also die fehlen sozusagen, wo einfach drin steht, von wem wir jetzt abhängig sind. Das ist natürlich auch eine wahnsinnig große Verlogenheit, die wieder zeigt, dass Kripoz Busch hier recht hat, zu sagen, wir haben nicht die Wahrheit und Putin hat die Narrative, sondern wir haben auch die Narrative und wir erzählen sie uns gerade nicht in voller Breite, sondern wie du sagst, wir warten einfach ein paar Jahre, bis das Problem dann drückt und dann reden wir halt darüber. Aber es einfach nur auf der zeitlichen Dimension zu verschieben, hat ja noch nie besonders gut funktioniert. Also in der Hinsicht, das ist schon alles auch ziemlich blöde, einfach was wir hier erleben.
Genau, und das ist das richtige Wort, blöde. Das ist das Wort, denn wir könnten die bessere Narrative tatsächlich haben. Das ist ja die Sache. Also es geht ja jetzt nicht uns um einen Relativismus, dass wir sagen, am Ende sind wir alle gleich, ob das jetzt ein Putin ist oder ein Olaf Scholz oder so. Keineswegs. Sondern wir hätten die besseren Narrative. Wir könnten zum Beispiel die Energiewende jetzt in anderer Weise deichseln. Wir müssten das nicht so machen, dass wir uns neue Abhängigkeiten begeben. Das heißt, wir könnten jetzt diese Narrative aufmachen, um wirklich zu zeigen, hier das ist die sinnvollere, bessere. Ich will nicht mit das moralisch werten, aber es ist die sinnvollere Alternative, die wir anbieten, wie wir unsere Zukunft, unsere Demokratien, all das gestalten. Und das findet aber nicht gerade statt. Man verkündet eine Zeitenwende, aber man, wie ich es gesagt hab, diversifiziert das Autokratenportfolio und ist damit zwar unabhängiger, aber man ist nicht besser dadurch geworden. Man wirtschaftet nicht sinnvoller dadurch. Das ist das große Versäumnis, das mich auch so traurig macht. Ich bin alt genug, um zu wissen, wenn Politiker verkünden, dieses Mal wird alles anders, dann weiß ich, es wird dann doch nicht anders werden. Aber dass man es so sehr, wo die Chancen auf der Straße liegen, liegen lässt und stattdessen jetzt wieder so weiterwurschtelt, das finde ich tatsächlich ungeheuer enttäuschend. Und wir haben diese Scholz-Rede vor der UN. Du hast uns mitgebracht, uns angehört. Und man macht sich dann irgendwann in der Welt sehr unglaubwürdig. Weil die dann sagen, na gut, ihr kommt jetzt hier mit einer moralischen, mit einem moralischen Narrativ an. Aber wie passt das dann jetzt mit Aliyev und mit Saudi-Arabien und so weiter zusammen? Und dann haben die ja zu Recht, stehen die da und sagen dann, ihr seid ja auch total relativistisch. Und dass man überhaupt diese Angriffsfläche bietet, das ist das große Problem. Und es ist auch das Problem, dass das Light-Medial so wenig abgebildet wird. Es gibt ganz viele kritische Artikel zu Aserbaidschan und sonst was. Ich hab ja auch immer wieder hier Sachen dieser Art mitgebracht im Podcast. Man findet dazu viel. Und hier nochmal das große Lob an die öffentlich-rechtlichen Radiosender mit ihren sehr guten Features zu allen möglichen Ländern. Aber Light-Medial findet das natürlich keinen Einzug und ist dann auch nicht Fokus der Landsendung von heute Morgen oder übermorgen.
Genau, ich will zu diesem Blog einen abschließenden Gedanken äußern, der mir kam und ich auch dachte, ja, das wär, also man muss es dann auch wirklich mal sagen, gerade wenn man sich so kritisch äußert wie wir zum Zeitgeist und den politischen Fortgang. Eine der Fragen auf Twitter, die auf deine Statements im Presseclub kamen, war ja, ja was würdest du dann machen, so im Sinne von ja, also dann kaufen wir jetzt keinen Gas bei anderen Autokraten, sondern frieren uns dann durch den Winter und wie zwei Jahre Dürre in Deutschland. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn wir feststellen, dass wir auf dieses Gas keinen Zugriff mehr haben, sollten wir uns kurz mit uns selbst beschäftigen und feststellen, aha, die letzten 20 Jahre haben wir einen mega krassen volkswirtschaftlichen Vorteil daraus gezogen, dass sich Angela Merkel und Gerhard Schröder sehr gut mit Putin verstanden haben. Jetzt auf Putin einzuschlagen, nachdem er die Grundlage dafür gelegt hat, dass wir 20 Jahre allen davon gezogen sind, einfach durch billige Energie. Also Volksverschaffende haben zwei große Vorteile, wenn sie erstens billige Energie und billige Arbeitskräfte haben. Gerhard Schröder hat für billige Energie und billige Arbeitskräfte gesorgt, den größten Niedriglohnsektor Europas geschaffen und gleichzeitig noch die Energie durch so eine Sauna-Freundschaft irgendwie mit Putin da Grund gelegt. Und dann hat Merkel diesen Pfad einfach weitergegangen und hat sozusagen die ganze Solar- und andere Branchen kurzum klein geschlagen, um da dieses Statement zu machen. Wir werfen uns gerne deine Abhängigkeit. Lass einfach das Gas billig. Und das fliegt uns jetzt um die Ohren. Heißt aber, in dem Fall haben wir wirklich mal ein großes Polster volkswirtschaftlich, um uns darauf auszuruhen. Was bedeutet? Meine Entscheidung als Bundeskanzler wäre, ich stelle zumindest in einer Rede die Alternative mal explizit in den Raum zu sagen, Leute, wir müssen auf 20% Gas verzichten. Was bedeutet? Der Gaspreis bleibt, wie er ist, für die 80% des Vorniveaus jedes Verbrauchers. Also jeder Haushalt kriegt genau zum selben Preis wie zum Vorjahr oder eben mit ganz kleinen Schwankungen diese 80%. Alles darüber hinaus wird zum Marktpreis vergeben. Und alles über 150% Verbrauch wird dann vielleicht sogar zu Marktpreisen, die wir noch im süderkumpischen Sinne künstlich erhöhen, um Umverteilungsmodus zu schaffen. Also zusätzlich noch einen Fonds aufzubauen, um die unteren, ärmeren Bevölkerungshälfte zu unterstützen. Was dann eben konkret bedeutet, nein, wir lassen kein Schiff irgendwie aus Katar usw. hier anlanden. Und das dauert ja eh noch eine Weile. Wir beginnen erst gar nicht mit der Planung, sondern wir sparen jetzt einfach. Jeder spart. Zuhause wird nur mit 19 Grad geheizt. Also nicht mal mit 22. Jedes einzelne Grad spart 6 Prozent der Heizkosten usw. Da ist man relativ zügig bei 20 Prozent. Und mehr als Heizung und Duschen ist es ja meistens nicht. Wir haben ja nicht wirklich dieses Energieproblem, sondern es ist dieses Wärmeproblem.
Na ja, Heizen ist schon viel. Heizen ist schon viel. Also 19 Grad ist happig.
Ja, wir haben jetzt auch Hausschuhe gekauft. Also wir müssen leider durch so ein tiefes Tal durch, durch unseren eigenen Fehler. Wir müssen tatsächlich echt verzichten. Diese Ausweichbewegungen sind die falschen.
Die Sache ist ja auch, diese Ausweichbewegungen sind ja nicht kurzfristige Sachen. Nur die lassen sich einmal kurzfristig zwar einfädeln. Aber es glaubt ja hoffentlich niemand, dass Saudi-Arabien oder Aserbaidschan Verträge jetzt machen für 16 Monate oder so. Das ist ja nicht ein Zeitungsabo, das man mal für ein Jahr abschließt. Sondern das sind ja langfristige Verträge. Und die wollen nicht, dass wir 2024, wenn mehr Windräder und alles, dass wir da rauskommen, sondern das ist wieder eine neue Abhängigkeit, in die wir uns auch hineinbegeben für 10, 15, 20 Jahre. Denn sonst macht das ja für die überhaupt keinen Sinn, eine Infrastruktur aufzumachen.
Ja, manchmal haben wir einfach Probleme, die sich nur bewältigen, aber nicht verdrängen lassen. Da muss man dann einfach durch. Also manche Leiterfahrungen muss man einfach dann mal machen. Und wir haben einfach zu krass profitiert, um jetzt zu sagen, nee, dann machen wir einfach die nächste Ausweichbewegung. Diese deutsche Arroganz. Und wir sehen das ja auch schon wieder bei dem abermaligen 200 Milliarden Doppelwumms und so weiter, wie wir es uns schon wieder verspielen in Europa. Weil natürlich die Europafinanzminister jetzt zusammenkamen und alle an den hinten fragten, müsst ihr wieder in Deutschland alle Unternehmen einzeln hier raus? Wir haben gar keine Chance mehr, da mitzuhalten. Weil in Deutschland wieder alles gerettet und mit Not und so weiter, Notprogramm zugedeckt wird.
Und zugleich sagt man aber ja keine gemeinschaftliche Verschuldung.
Das kommt dann dazu, genau. Lieber lass mal die italienische Regierung hops gehen, als da nur ein Zugeständnis an neue Verschuldungsregeln zu machen. Und selbst Ursula von der Leins Vorschlag, den wir ja besprochen haben, da wird natürlich erst mal keinen Anklang finden. Das ist ein großes, großes Drama. Es sind noch zwei Külpersbusch-Clips, willst du die noch spielen? Okay, hier steht Külpersbusch und Sohn, ich bin gespannt.
Du hast ja auch zwei erwachsene Söhne.
Also das vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, wie die eingestellt sind. Ja, ich hab Bezug auf meinen Sohn, der ist 31. Die Frage an Frau Baerbock, nachdem sein Großonkel Ernst in der Ukraine liegt, ist es die zwingende Konsequenz, dass mein Sohn sich danebenlegt? Können Sie mir das mal erklären?
Worauf er hier anspielt, ist, dass er aus einer Familie kommt, wo beim Kaffeetisch einige Stühle immer leerblieben. Da saßen die ganzen Witwen der im Krieg zurückgebliebenen, der Gefallenen. Und diese Tanten sitzen da und sagen, ach ja, wie wäre das jetzt, wenn Karl Heinz da wäre? Der müsste jetzt auch schon 50 sein. Das sind die Dialoge, die er als Kind hört. Er wird dann gefragt, was er werden will. Und dann reden sie ihm, einer soll Lokomotivführer werden, weil die so wichtig sind für die Infrastruktur. Die werden nicht an die Front geschickt. Das ist die Überlegung dann da. Sein Vater war eine Sportskanone, aber ist auch verletzt im Krieg so sehr, dass er nur noch mündliche Anweisungen gibt, wie ein Fahrrad zu fahren ist, wie zu schwimmen ist usw. Und in diesem Umfeld wächst er auf, sagt er hat dadurch natürlich eine andere Geschichte. Und dieser Onkel Ernst, der da in der Ukraine gefallen ist, sagt er auch, der ist ja Teil eines verbrecherischen Krieges gewesen. Und insofern muss man in dem Sinne ganz klar sagen, der war auf der Täterseite, aber der ist ja nicht freiwillig unbedingt dahingerannt, bzw. er ist tot. Und das ist so eine sehr gute Aussage nochmal. Ja, aber gestorben wurde ja trotzdem. Und ich habe jetzt gerade die Neuverfilmung von Im Westen Nichts Neues gesehen. Die wird Ende des Monats bei Netflix kommen. Die kann man jetzt schon in ausgewählten Kinos sehen, was ich besonders empfehle. Denn diese Bilder schreien nach der großen Leinwand. Und ich kann es nur jedem empfehlen, sich diese wirklich herausragende Neuverfilmung anzusehen. Eine Filmanalyse werde ich schon noch dazu machen. Es ist so herausragend herausgestellt, was eigentlich Krieg bedeutet. Und auch diese Idee 1914. Aber dieses Mal wird es schon gut gehen. Diesmal ist der Krieg anders als andere Kriege. Dieser Glaube, dieser Krieg wird auch der letzte sein. Es ist erstaunlich präzise herausgearbeitet, was es eigentlich mit Menschen macht. Es ist ganz herausragend. Und das ist auch ein Diskurs, dieser pazifistische, ganz grundsätzliche Diskurs, den ich in den Leitmedien vermisse. Wir hören mal noch weiter.
Dann endet für mich die Debatte auch nicht darin, dass wir endlich schwere Waffen liefern, die dann in der Hand des ukrainischen Freiheitskämpfers toll funktionieren und die Kugel verlässt den Lauf. Und jetzt ist der Gerechtigkeit, sondern für mich geht es noch den Moment weiter, wo diese Kugel in der Stirn eines 18-jährigen, dummen russischen Jungen einschlägt.
Und genau das zeigt im Westen nichts Neues. Und das ist das, was ich wirklich jedem nochmal empfehlen kann und dann auch nochmal überprüfen, sollte man den Twitter-Diskurs, also im Twitter wird es ja auch gleich in unserem Gespräch gehen, den Twitter-Diskurs, der da von Ökonomen, Militärberatern und so weiter geführt wird, wo man inzwischen Herzchen-Smilies macht, wenn man in Deutschland eine neue nukleare Teilhabe anstrebt und so weiter. Also man wirklich auf einem Niveau angekommen ist, wo dann nicht mehr klar ist, like ich jetzt gerade das neue Video von Bibi oder schon die Atombombe.
Ja, da kriegen wir sehr gute Aufklärung in dem Buch, denn ja, wir werden es gleich besprechen. Die beiden machen nicht die große Bandbreite, sondern gehen so ganz punktuell rein und treffen diese wunden Punkte. Also ich kann nur...
Aber ich kann auch sagen, ich werde das Buch kritisch besprechen, denn ich bin mit einigen überhaupt nicht einverstanden. Also ich glaube, ich bin sehr gespannt, wir haben uns nicht ausgetauscht darüber. Ich weiß gar nichts, ich kann nur schon mal ankündigen, dass ich mit einigen ganz und gar nicht einverstanden bin und manche Fehler sogar da sagen würde, sind unterlaufen. Und nicht irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten irgendwas nicht richtig zitiert, sondern wo ich glaube, das ist argumentativ extrem schief. Und ich glaube, dass auch sie nicht ganz im Jetzt angekommen sind, denn es gibt ein Medium zum Beispiel, das nicht vorkommt. Das ist das, was wir hier machen, Podcast. Aber wir werden über all das reden.
Dann lass mich einen Teaser noch machen, denn die beiden saßen bei Lanz und dann haben sie den Vorwurf bekommen, es ist eine Streitschrift. Und dann hat Wälzer glaube ich gesagt, nee, es ist ja keine Streitschrift, sondern einfach so eine Zeitdiagnose und so weiter. Ich würde sagen, dieses Buch ist natürlich ein Beitrag in einem Krieg, der ohne Waffen läuft, sondern mit Worten. Der aber wirklich auf der Ebene, wir haben es ja wirklich mit Vernichtungsansinnen und so weiter zu tun. Und das ließ sich besonders gut aufzeigen an dieser Land-Sendung, wo man auf der Beziehungsebene gar nichts mehr vorfand, sondern nur noch bewusst kontraproduktiv reingehen wollte, um so kleine Punktgewinne im Krieg zu machen. Und das kennen wir aus dem Krieg. Klar hat der Feldherr so eine große Idee von und so weiter, aber am Ende verteidigt man nur noch seinen Kameraden. Und da geht es nur noch um kleine minutiösen Punktgewinne, die man halt so einfährt. Und am Ende werden alle sterben. Das ist der alte Platonsatz. Nur die Toten haben das Ende des Krieges gesehen. Und das ist natürlich ein echtes Problem. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Beitrag in einem Krieg zu tun, in einem Informationskrieg, in dem wir natürlich uns schon lange verfangen haben und zu denen auch gilt, bricht der Krieg einmal los, sind die Regeln, die vorher aufgestellt wurden, egal. Also wer hier irgendwelche akademischen Regeln noch einlegt, nee, da muss er auch noch mal eine Reflektionsschleife drehen. Und das werden wir ja gleich machen. Genau, was haben wir noch gelesen? Es gibt mehrere Themenblöcke. Zum einen Demografie und Russland. Das finde ich natürlich sehr gut, dass es jetzt so kleine Textgrundlagen gibt, die nochmal darauf hinweisen, wie die demografische Lage in Russland eigentlich ist. Russland ist das erste Mal in Krieg gezogen oder in so eine Verteidigungsposition gekommen. Also, will ich ausdrücklich sagen, weil Zweiter Weltkrieg war für Russland eine Verteidigungsposition, bis sie dann Europa befreit haben, wo wirklich die Demografie mal umgedreht. Warum wurde Russland damals überfallen? Man suchte Lebensraum im Osten. Heute fragt man sich, für wen denn? Das ist bei Russland natürlich auch. Haben wir eigentlich noch Soldaten zum Opfern?
Weil man ja immer fragt, warum macht Putin das? Das ist immer das Größte, was macht er mit dem Land, da er die Leute jetzt rauben will? Was hat er am Ende davon? Von den so und so vier Quadratkilometern, Hektar?
Dazu gibt es gute Textgrundlagen. Der Hunger ist zurück in Deutschland, was ja bedeutet, Einkommensarmut führt zu Qualitätsminderung in der Ernährung, was ein echtes Problem ist. Niemand muss absolut hungern, aber der relative Hunger ist doch relativ groß. Es gibt sehr gute Texte, die mal aufzeigen, was wir so langsam vermuten. Die Bio-Branche ist ja gerade im, das tiefste Tal aller Zeiten durch. Das ist eine Branche, die nur Wachstum kannte und jetzt liegt sie am Boden, was eben bedeutet, Menschen haben weniger Geld für ihr Essen. Dann wird es noch um Klimafolgen geben. Es ist erstaunlich, dass wir so wenig über Pakistan gesprochen haben, aber in den Blättern wurde mal das Hochwasser dort so ein bisschen in Zahlen ausgedrückt. Und David Wallace Wells hat eine Studie geteilt, die sich mal den volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden, der erwartet wird, bis zum Ende des Jahrhunderts in Kanada angeschaut. Ein Land, wo wir gerade gar keine Klima irgendwie und so, da ist ja gerade nichts, also ein paar Waldbrände ab und zu. Und es sind wirklich erschreckende Zahlen, die für uns Deutsche besonders, weil wir sind noch höher gerankt in verschiedenen Studien, German Marshall Funch und so weiter, die immer so Klimafolgenabschätzung machen. Also alles hochgradig dramatisch, was wir da noch lesen werden.
Ich hatte angekündigt, das Buch von Nick Lent zu besprechen mit Texten von ihm und dieser Korrespondenz mit Dietmar Daert. Und ich kam nach Hause und dann habe ich gerade die Mitteilung erhalten, dass dieses Buch verschoben ist auf Frühjahr. Deswegen habe ich es jetzt nicht dabei natürlich. Und ich habe aber andere, längere, sehr interessante Texte, und zwar, auch hier spielt Ernährung eine Rolle, und zwar in China, da wird ja unglaublich viel gehortet, zum Beispiel Weizen. Es heißt hier, dass man über die Hälfte des weltweiten Weizens in Kammern gelagert hat und man fragt sich, warum. Das versucht dann, ein längerer Text einmal aufzudröseln, was dahinter stecken könnte. Dann ein sehr eigenartiges Phänomen, das Tamagotchi-Ei ist noch wohl bekannt, aber es gibt jetzt so eine Neuauflage. Man kann sich jetzt Mitglieder von BTS, also dieser K-Pop-Band, als Tamagotchi halten. Und das hat eine Autorin dann mal eine Weile gemacht und hat das beschrieben in einem Text, was es eigentlich bedeutet. Dann ein Text zu Brasilien von Alex Hociuli, von dem haben wir auch schon mal ein Buch gelesen. Und der setzt sich mit Brasilien auseinander, aber nicht mit Lula und nicht mit Bolsonaro, sondern er beschäftigt sich mit dem dritten Kandidaten, der eigentlich der Interessanteste ist, weil man an ihm Brasilien, wie es sich entwickelt hat, neu verstehen kann. Denn Brasilien ist eigentlich nicht mehr das katholische Land, das kollektivistische Land, das sinnliche Land, sondern eine Coaching-Ideologie hat Einzug gehalten und die wird immer populärer. Und dann habe ich noch eine Studie, eine neue DAC-Studie zu den Jugendlichen. Während der Pandemie sind sie zum Arzt gegangen, welche Diagnosen gab es? Und da stellt sich heraus, besonders schlimm, was Essstörungen und Mental Health anbelangt, hat es die Mädchen getroffen. Also ganz erschreckende Zahlen. Und dann zum Schluss blicken wir noch auf das Influencer-Business. Da habe ich so eine Marketing-Zeitschrift. Und da liest man mal zahlen, was denn so eigentlich verdient wird.
Sehr gut.
Dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich im Salon.
Zum Schluss gratulieren wir dann noch Stephen King in der Hoffnung, dass wir hier Leserempfehlungen abgeben können. Ich bin ja selber nicht so ein Stephen-King-Leser, aber wir werden klären, warum eigentlich nicht. Gut, tschüss gleich.
Ach so, wir sollten noch ganz kurz sagen, wie man in den Salon kommt für die, die das jetzt noch nicht bislang verfolgt haben. Also man kommt in den Salon über die neue 20er.de Seite. Also da kann man dann eine Mitgliedschaft über Steady buchen. Es ist aber auch möglich, das über Apple direkt zu buchen, wenn man über Apple Podcasts hört. Dann gibt es noch Patreon für diejenigen, die schon da sind. Und haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen? Und man kann es über Spotify direkt buchen. Aber nochmal hier ausdrücklich, nur wenn man über Steady bucht, hat man das gesamte Podcastarchiv, also den alle Salon-Folgen, die es gibt, während es bei den anderen, erst die jüngeren Folgen sind, die da hochgeladen sind. Außerdem gibt es noch Vorteile wie Kapitelmarken und so etwas. Also Steady ist das, was man präferieren kann, aber der Bequemlichkeit halber gehen natürlich auch die anderen Wege.
Genau. Gebt euch nicht mit wenig zufrieden. Bei Steady bekommt ihr Kapitelmarken. Sehr wichtig, häufig nachgefragt. Sie sind drin. Wenn sie euch nicht angezeigt werden, haut noch irgendwas nicht hin. Ihr könnt euren eigenen RSS-Feed einfach abonnieren im Podcast-Player eurer Wahl. Dann wird euch das Cover angezeigt, dann seht ihr gleich, ah ja, hier wird Precht Wälzer gelesen, weil ich sehe das Cover von dem Buch. Und es gibt Kapitelmarken. Man kann dann hin und her springen und so weiter. Alles drin und ihr findet das auch. Bis gleich.